so between rise of Skywalker and force
awakens I'm wondering which character
changed the most after you cast the role
well I'll say it wasn't so much that any
one character changed more than another
but I know that on force awakens the
energy that that between Rey and Finn
for example was was a different thing at
the beginning you know we'd written a
little bit more of a kind of contentious
kind of relationship and as we were
shooting scenes I was just feeling like
it wasn't popping it wasn't really
working and then I'd say cut and then
Daisy and John would be like they would
just be like the greatest of friends and
had these this amazing sort of you know
a partay and I was like what the hell is
like every time I say cut it was so much
better than when I was saying action and
so we literally went back and and
rewrote their dynamic not so much their
characters but just sort of who they
were to each other so that it was a bit
more you know in line with and in sync
with kind of who we actually had and
what was clearly naturally the the
energy that was there was between them
yeah they're amazing and by the way just
sorry John and Oscar from the beginning
were immediately like weirdly
wonderfully on fire like that was that
was from the get-go